- You did something that I
like vowed to never do again
because this is a very hard thing to do.
I've sang at a few funerals
in my life and it's just
the hardest scenario ever.
- Yeah.
- If you know them or if you
don't, it doesn't matter.
Because you're seeing other
peoples pain regardless,
and it's just painful.
- Yeah.
- But you actually performed
at George Floyd's funeral.
So how did you get involved?
- Yeah.
I believe the family reached out.
I got the information from my manager,
so I didn't speak directly to the family.
But, I believe they reached
out and asked if I would sing
and I mean of course I said yeah.
So we got down there.
I tried to sit, a little
further back you know,
'cause I didn't want the
moment to be about me at all.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean,
like I didn't want to
do the celebrity thing,
I didn't want that.
But when they saw me they pulled me up
to a closer pew and I'm
like "all right, cool."
So, I'm sitting there
and, I get up on stage,
and the second I got up
there, I look in the audience
and his daughter's sitting
right in front of me.
And then all I could see in
that moment was my daughter.
And--
I broke.
I couldn't, I--
- It's the hardest
thing to do.
It's sing at some, yeah--
- Yeah I couldn't get
my words together or what I wanted to say,
that came out wrong,
some people misunderstood
what I meant by that.
Whatever--
- I know that's
kinda the rough thing too is I feel like,
I heard there was a bit of
blow back from the funeral.
Did that hit you hard?
Like to where you were like
"wait, that was totally mis--
"that was twisted."
- You know what, initially.
I won't lie, initially it did.
'Cause I'll be honest,
my manager called me and told me
about what was being said or whatever
and I instantly got upset like "what?"
Like how could anybody really think
that I would stand up
at this mans funeral,
in front of this mans family,
and mean anything
negative or wrong about--
Like how could anybody make that mistake?
Right?
- Yeah.
- So, I got upset and my response was
"you know what?
"Intelligent people knew what I meant."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And anybody ignorant,
I ain't worried about it.
But then my manager had to catch me,
he's like "no, that's not what this is.
"This moment is really really
really important, okay?
"The least you could do
is take a few minutes
"to make sure that people understand
"what it is you're saying, okay?
"Because ignorance is division.
"And we don't need division
right now all right?
"We need to do this right now.
- Wow.
- "So take a second.
"Explain what it is you meant.
"Not because anyone is
owed an explanation,
"but because it's the right thing to do,
"in order for unity to
be part of the narrative.
"Not division."
- Yeah.
- You know so
I took it upon myself.
I went into the comments
and I answered some people.
Somebody said "he wasn't
sacrificed, he was murdered."
And I'm like, okay well,
in the realm of a lot of sacrifices
they kind of involve death.
I mean it's unfortunate.
It's unfortunate that
his death was the spark
that caused this energy
that is slowly but surely
creating change for us.
But the truth of the matter is,
this mans life was sacrificed
in order for this to happen.
Now I don't think
that was the reasoning behind
it initially of course.
The cops killed him and it was wicked,
it was meant for wicked.
But, we then took something
that was meant for wicked
and turned it into a positive.
- Yeah.
No, I agree.